very sad was the passing of Bill Paxton
yeah
passed away and I mean the guy has been
in so many different movies and very
young and passed away and I was just
online and of course as people do they
they they start tweeting these things
and all the biggest stars in Hollywood
reading what a nice guy yeah Bill Paxton
was and people say that you hear that a
lot about oh he's a nice guy so nice
today
but everybody was unanimously saying one
of the nicest people I've ever worked
with and in addition to being incredibly
talented and I was thinking about this
thing that I actually witnessed Bill
Paxton do and that made me realize oh my
god they're right they're absolutely
right which was Bill Paxton was in the
movie tombstone mm-hmm I don't know how
many people here know tombstone but it's
got some amazing performances Kurt
Russell's in it Val Kilmer's in it and
Bill Paxson's in it and just you know
just Sam Elliott's in it it's just an
amazing movie it's great and people go
nuts for it
and I'm a huge fan of the movie
tombstone and this our field producer
Jason shalini who's been chasing
celebi's been with us since what day one
yeah yeah so he was with us and Jason
show Lemmy and I find out that Val
Kilmer is gonna be doing a play not far
from where we tape here in Burbank yeah
and he's gonna be playing Mark Twain
yeah and we go and see it and it turns
out he was amazing
he's amazing doing Mark Twain but we go
to see Val Kilmer in this play and we
get in and we're taking our seats and
all the sudden someone taps me on the
shoulder and it's Bill Paxton it's
really good and then I say I just got to
tell you how much I love tombstone
what an amazing would be tombstone is
and I say I had to tell you that's my
mine producer over there Jason chill
Emmy who's been with me since he was
like a kid since he was like 18 and
tombstone is one of his favorite movies
and Bill Paxton went which guy see which
guys eNOS is right there Jason he's his
name's Jason yeah and he goes over he
walks over to Jason he goes hey Jason
and he starts whispering in Jason's ear
jason has a beard and it all
falls off in his eyes get big as
quarters and he's like and he's doing
this for a while and then he walked away
and I'm like what the hell did he say
did she I go over to Jason and Jason's
not a famous guy reading and he spent
quite a while with him and he said he
just leaned over and he recited to me
quietly all of his lines from tombstone
[Laughter]
such a sweet man I just wanted to I
wanted to share that because that's one
of those things where when you witness
true kindness true humanity you feel
like okay let's just take a second what
a great man yeah what a great guy